well we turn now to Hurricane Maria
which left Puerto Rico's hospitals in
critical condition 59 of the island 69
hospitals are open in some capacity but
some of them are worried they won't have
enough fuel and other supplies to keep
going dr. Jon LaPook is in San Juan
talking with patients and doctors about
their fears as the crisis continues John
good morning good morning bianna for
many of those injured here the crisis
isn't just continuing its increasing
they've had a wait for treatment and
many could soon run out of medications
and there's another problem the shortage
of clean fresh water is especially
dangerous for people with underlying
medical issues so are you looking for
help I'm looking for a lot of help dr.
sherry and PRA is the head of obstetrics
and gynecology at University District
Hospital number one there's no
communications number two there's a lot
of uncertainty about our power about how
we're gonna get things done how our so
when our supplies are going to run out
because of the widespread devastation
many of Puerto Rico's medical facilities
are closed this hospital is seeing
emergencies from the entire island but
with resources limited triage tents have
been set up on a driveway to treat
patients arriving by ambulance every
patient here has their own story of
adversity
this woman drove her injured husband to
two closed hospitals before arriving 36
year-old marcelina lopez is six months
pregnant she fell during the hurricane
and it took her two days to reach the
hospital they you know they had four
miscarriages and told me she's concerned
about how she'll get to the hospital
if something happens this is turning
rapidly into a healthcare crisis a
crisis for the patients and the doctors
who care for them I see your eyes
starting to moisten as you talk about
this this is very emotional for you it's
extremely emotional this is not this is
unparalleled
we have never witnesses anything like
this before Gale doctors here told me
that they don't even know how many
people are out there maybe stuck at home
unable to call 911
that's some pregnant women even those
that high-risk have been forced to
deliver at home they walk into the
hospital's carrying their newborns
doctor Jon LaPook in Puerto Rico thank
you